[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines this
evening we're joined by the columnist
carol malone and the editor of the
courier david clegg thank you both so
much for joining us this evening they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what is to come on
some of those front pages and the
telegraph leads with the energy price
cap rise
stating that the new prime minister will
offer urgent help with bills as the
price cap doubles
tomorrow's eye paper also focuses its
attention on the cost of living crisis
with the headline uk hit by record hike
in energy prices
liz truss has pledged support for help
with soaring energy bills if she is
voted in as prime minister the daily
mail rights
the times also leads on liz truss's
plans to help people with energy bills
with homes braced for the price cap rise
on friday
also focused on the potential future
prime minister tomorrow's financial
times reads trust ways triggering
article 16 to buy time on northern
ireland protocol
saying that the frontrunner seeks swift
action if she succeeds boris johnson as
prime minister
sorted out the metro's front page
features the moment the health secretary
stephen barclay was heckled by a
passerby live on tv
over ambulance waiting times
the guardian's front page turns its
attention to the north-south divide seen
in this year's gcse results with a
headline gap in gcse results brings
fresh warnings over coved
the courier leads with the promise of
further union strike action this time by
school staff in scotland its headline
warning schools may close
and the queen could appoint the next
prime minister at balmoral rather than
buckingham palace where the appointment
is traditionally made
according to the sun
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us and tonight to take us
through them we are joined by the
columnist karen malone and the editor of
the courier david clegg and thank you
both again very much for joining us
the the energy price cap announcement
we're expecting tomorrow from 7am it has
been enormously trailed throughout the
week and it seems to be what so many of
the papers have gone with tonight
um
you know just just talking about it
in the last hour it could go up by 1 500
pounds and that could be the first rise
of many to come carol it's just an
extraordinary sum of money isn't it and
and i
i just cannot comprehend how people are
going to suddenly find this money down
the back of the sofa it's just not going
to happen
jane it's not going to happen you know
we've been talking about this this um
cap for a long time now but suddenly
it's just become terrifyingly real and
and the idea that households are going
to be able to pay double what the what
they're now paying is beyond and yes the
government are talking about you know
we'll say nothing sahabi there
chancellor was saying that as soon as
the new prime minister was elected in
and on september 5th there if it's liz
trust which we think it's going to be
she's going to make some and speedy
announcements on how to help people and
there's there were lots of options on
the table and and i was reading this and
i was thinking god if any of these
happen they'd be good they're saying
they could increase the 400 pounds to
every family they could scrap the fat on
energy bills which would save households
at least five percent they could scrap
them so they've scrapped they've out for
small businesses that would save them 20
because of course today there's been
stories and all the papers saying a lot
of small businesses are gonna have to
close down before the end of winter
because of energy bills and they're also
talking about freezing the cap at the
level it is now and the reduction of um
green energy levels levies which you
know
that's going to have to happen i think
so there is some hope for people out
there um it's not going to stop anyone
panicking it's not going to stop people
on low incomes who are struggling now
because that's the other stories we're
reading people are saying now that they
can't cope and and you know the cap
hasn't happened yet so it is if this is
becoming a terrifying reality my terror
my
my real terror is for the elderly who
you know a lot of these these people
depend on nothing but the state pension
they have about 250 quid a week and it's
just you know it's like that's no that's
that's an exaggeration that don't have
as much as that it's less than 200
children for a few weeks and they're
gonna have to heat their homes i mean i
just i fear that a lot of elderly people
are gonna die this winter because
even now i was on a tv show recently
where they were talking about
one old lady said she was staying in bed
even now so she didn't have to get up to
switch the gas on to cook to do stuff
for herself so if it's like that now in
august god only knows what it's gonna be
like because it's been the summer um
david just bringing you in and just to
to echo what carol said our one of our
reports that we've been carrying on sky
news tonight featured a lady who was 81
and she has had to start using the food
bank for the first time and she was
saying she's not going to pay a bill and
and you know do you think many people
are going to be following her example
that there are going to be people who
are just going to say i just can't
afford to pay it and i'm just not going
to pay it
i think we're in a very desperate
situation i think this is actually a
national emergency
to go from monthly bills of 100 pound a
year ago to 300 pounds every month uh
from the from october perhaps i mean
that's just
it's just not possible to to deal with
those kind of increases for people who
are
already struggling so i think there will
definitely be people who are in a
situation where not they don't they
don't pay as they simply can't pay
uh you know the st i saw the report
you're referring to there we also had a
story in scotland about pensioners you
know using their bus pass just to travel
around in the bus because at least it's
warm on the bus i think we we are
getting into that desperate situation
but i think i think the thing that we're
going to hear from uh liz trussa uh
in the days ahead because she's she's
had quite a journey here because this
has been this has been a slow
car crash unfolding because we've known
that this day is coming and we've been
pretty clear about what was going to
happen but in the early days of the tory
leadership race liz trust was quite
reluctant to promise more action we're
getting big signals that that's changing
and it's clear that if as we uh suspect
or as the polls are predicting liz trust
is the next prime minister that she she
will actually take quite significant
steps now she will have to and it is
going to cost a significant amount of
money but
it seems to me that the only thing that
can be done here is public money is
going to have to be plowed into this it
is that type of covert like crisis that
we're facing here so that's the the
immediate
that is going to be needed but i also
think with what has also become clear
during this process is that the
wholesale market for energy is broken uh
the government announced a review of
this last month but
it is very clear i think that the way
the system works at the minute
uh it's complicated nobody really
understands it it's not that no one's
bills are clear of how they've been
calculated and it really needs wholesale
change there as well but so there needs
to be this immediate action to help
people uh this winter but also we need
to we need to make sure that we we we
change the system so that uh there's
more clarity and the prices are are held
closer uh in a way that can be
controlled carl you're trying to get in
there
i was just gonna say that this what
david was talking about immediate help
they're talking about freezing this cap
and that could cost a hundred billion
over the next two years that's the
figures that have been muted and we're
talking about you know you're talking
about elderly people saying they they
won't pay because they can't pay what
worries me about that because i think
there'll be a lot of people not just the
elderly who would be like that and
there's this don't pay campaign around
now but that frightens me too because
if they don't pay it doesn't mean
they're never going to have to pay it
means that debt is going to follow them
around for the rest of their lives they
could be dragged into court there could
be no they could have a criminal record
as a result of this and that can't be
allowed to happen to the poorest people
in this country which is why the
measures have to be put in place as
david says
as quickly as they possibly can be we're
told there will be so
nadine sahabi said today they would be
in the days after liz dross if it comes
to power they will be put in place but
you know as david says it is it is
almost too late you know
everyone's on there some holidays at the
moment no work is being done in downtown
these plans should have been hatched
weeks and weeks ago and and in place for
september october but they they haven't
been it's scary
and the frustration the frustration
about that is that it's not like we
weren't warned that we didn't know it
was coming i was when i was i mean carl
talked about this exact same issue a
month ago on this program and we were we
were saying the exact same thing it
seems it's taken the government a little
while to to get to where everybody else
has been for a long time and i think the
the reporting on this uh in the papers
tomorrow is quite interesting because
there's clearly been a briefing from the
liz trust camp uh and from the
chancellor and they're they're they're
making the point that uh the main
driving force between these price rises
is is is the war in ukraine and they're
blaming vladimir putin that you know
they're saying we can't be made the
people can't be made to suffer because
of what vladimir putin is doing so if
they are characterizing uh this as a
weapon of war then i think the the
argument there for uh significant
government intervention to protect
people who are going to be are going to
be the victims of this uh is even
heightened more so
i i it will be really interesting to see
exactly what they do and and how they
direct this money because there is a
very uh immediate political choice
coming for the new prime minister and
the stakes couldn't be higher really and
carol in terms of of who that new prime
minister will be i mean you know
most money is on this trust but you know
it's not over until the fat lady sings
is it um
but the poll that sky news carried out
today showed that she was bottom of all
the leaders in terms of people's
confidence and how she would handle
what what is to come that is a problem
isn't it
this doesn't surprise me in the
slightest you know i i listen
i don't think is anywhere near qualified
to be our next primers and the fact that
our prime minister has been chosen by a
few thousand tory party members is
insanity you know quite a part of the
fact that i don't think she's up to
handling this crisis i don't think she's
up to hunting any crisis her record has
not been fantastic she's been in
government for a very long time and not
made any significant progress and
suddenly she's going to be our next pm
and she's made a whole load of promises
jane in these election hostings which
she will never be able to keep and all
those promises are gonna come back and
bite her on the backside in the next few
months and i icf for this country with
liz trust at the helm i really do i
don't think for a second i think it's i
think the tories are in for electoral
oblivion come the next election um the
metro is is its front page uh stephen
barclay now he uh was heckled by a
passerby i mean we all love this even
i'm sure it's not just tv journalists
when this kind of thing happens uh a
lady's passing by she sees him being
interviewed
if we've got the clip actually but of
her putting her too penetrating about
emergency service weights
well don't you think 12 years is long
enough
yes 12 years you've done [ __ ] all
about it people have died and all you've
done is nothing
yeah it's excruciating for him isn't it
but um
you know great remember the public to
feel that she can have her say
uh david and uh and she's on the front
page of hey we don't have a name
actually i'm sure somebody does have her
name
i think what what's what was great about
it was a very good ambush because she
was while she was while she was angry
and passionate about the issue she was
also pretty succinct i'm glad that uh
i'm glad i'm glad that the bad language
was was used there so i don't need to i
don't need to repeat exactly what she
said but i think it does it does show
the the level of anger with this we've
seen some horrifying
statistics on some really terrible uh
cases uh where the the human the human
cost of this and i think everyone
understands that kuvit and the pandemic
and the the nhs more widely has been
under so much pressure from that but
also it is right that the the starting
point for this has been the nhs has been
underfunded uh for years and years and
so with this this crisis has boiled over
so i think i think um
yeah it was it it was a it was a funny
moment i thought the camera operator
there was doing very well not to look
gleeful as it was unfolding with with
the camera running besides uh but i
think i think it highlights uh
the anger about a much more important
issue he said look vanguard carol
well it's not strictly true that the nhs
has been underfunded this had 136
billion this year and more for covert on
top but i mean i love women like this
lady we'll find out her name in the
morning i'm sure because you know
because steve you could say nothing to
that it's not strictly true to say the
tories have done what she said um
of course they have but but like in the
past few weeks we've had terrible
stories about people waiting hours for
ambulances there was a terrible story
last week about a 90 year old lady
waiting 40 hours for an ambulance to
come and get her after a fall i mean you
know this is not what should happen in a
supposedly civilized country you cannot
have pensioners lying on the road you
cannot have people waiting 10 15 20
hours for an ambulance it's and i just i
think it's a
lot more than shortage of funds i think
it's about organization and i think the
nhs needs to reorganize itself better
and spend its money a bit better but
however you cut it this lady is quite
right because where she's standing
she's not getting a good service indeed
and final story david your paper uh the
courier the angus and dundee edition
schools potentially going to be striking
even as we just come into the new school
term a nightmare for parents this is
about pay
yes this is this is a local government
pay dispute which has uh had the bin men
on strike uh what you'll have seen the
pictures of the rubbish piled up in
edinburgh in particular when the
festival's on and they've not announced
today that that will also move to uh
staff in schools glasgow has has already
announced that all that schools will
close for these days in september when
there's going to be a striking from what
is largely caring staff and other school
staff but in my area where i am done the
angus pressure that will all be affected
as well we haven't haven't had clarity
from the council as well they're going
to close the schools for this as well
but i think we're just we're just seeing
you know this industrial unrest
everywhere when you're facing the kind
of energy bills that we've been
discussing already this evening uh that
the the the unions are are pushing hard
for uh for a pay offer that is going to
help their members deal with that
and i think we could be in for a lot
more unrest still to come